DEBUT TODAY.INJURY, NOT A
COVID ON THE PLAY.
>> Joe: BARCLAY GOODROW STILL
SHAKING HIS HEAD ON THE BENCH.
WHAT A CHANCE FOR HIM.
COMES RIGHT
>> Sam: YES.
HIS STICK CAME UP AS HE WAS
TRYING TO FIND THE DEFLECTED BYN
THE WAY IN. PUCK FROM THERE,
AND SO DOES CHRIS KREIDER IN
HIS OFFENSE AND HOW IMPORTANT. .
>> Sam: LIBOR HAJEK H
ALREADY.
AND THERE'S HUSTLE BYO RETRIEVE.
.
GOES AND GETS IT.
WHAT TROUBA ON
POINT.
UNDER A MINUTE TO GO PUCK.
AND IT'S CLEARED ASIDE. IGOR!S..
THEY WERE PAIRED IN THE GAME
STROME. FLORIDA
THAT'S
LIGHTNING WITH EIGHT WITH ZIBAN.
CHRIS KREIDER, ASSIST N
OF THE GOALTENDER.
SHOT HIT THE SIDE OF
BACKHANDED PASS BY ZIBANEJAD,D,
ON THE ICE TO START THE THIRD
SHESTERKIN MAKES ANOTHER SAVE,
HIS 37th OF ON
HIMVE,